guy millière bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin dans la matinale de rtl
france alors deux mois après la
présidentielle géorgie retrouve un ces
dernières heures des airs de campagne
d'envergure nationale avant la double
sénatoriales pourquoi ce scrutin est
décisif ce soutien très important parce
que ou bien comme cela a été dit dans le
reportage ou bien donald trump
parviendra à garder les républicains
parviendront à garder la majorité au
sénat et dans ce cas là les démocrates
n'auront pas les mains libres ou dans
l'autre quarts néo démocrates auront la
chambre des représentants et
vraisemblablement maintenant la
présidence et le sénat mais il faut
faire passer tout ce qu'ils veulent
et si beaucoup de gens s'inquiètent à
l'idée que les démocrates puissent faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est parce
qu'ils ont l'intention de transformer
très profondément le pays ayant
l'intention de transformer la cour
suprême ils ont intention de donner le
statut d'état deux territoires
supplémentaires
la ville de washington et porto rico ce
qui dans la mesure où les dote en
général à washington et à porto rico
sont des docks démocrate assurerait une
majorité très solide aux démocrates pour
de nombreuses élections à venir
et j'ajouterais qu'une multitude de
projets de loi qui ne passeraient pas si
les républicains l'égard de la majorité
ne pouvait être passé dans ces
conditions et donc les démocrates
pouvaient faire passer l'intégralité de
leurs programmes qui est un programme
très à gauche qui le programme le plus à
gauche qui ait jamais eu dans des
élections présidentielles américaines
le congrès qui doit valider les
résultats justement de l'élection
présidentielle pour invalider la
présidence de joe biden le 20 janvier
prochain
djahida nadeo giovan pardon donald trump
l'ue appelle ses partisans à venir
manifester à washington ils seront
nombreux salons vous je pense qu'ils
seront nombreux et je dirais que ce
qu'il importe de dire c'est que la
moitié de la population américaine
parce que des fraudes massives ont eu
lieu il ya des preuves
des fraudes massives ont eu lieu des
juges ont refusé d'examiner les preuves
mais nous sommes dans une situation très
délicate
quand vous avez la moitié de la
population du pays qui pensent que
l'élection était volée cela veut dire
que le président n'a pas de légitimité
en général un président est élu
normalement et il n'y a pas tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis deux mois ci s'est
passé tout cela depuis deux mois ci est
en raison de ce que je viens de dire
il ya une bonne partie de la population
américaine qui actuellement est très
frustré elle se dit les juges ne juge
plus des cours suprêmes ne déploie pas
la constitution
notre parti ne nous représente pas
vraiment et donc la présidence baydan
puisqu'elle maintenant il est quasiment
certain que by dane watts présidente va
commencer dans de très mauvaises
conditions et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela
que que john dryden ne peut pas car deux
des piles et elle ne doit pas organiser
quoi que ce soit pour le jour où il sera
sans doute
investi président et je dirais que
donald trump et reconnaîtra jamais sa
tablette pour nous à contrer ça c'est
que tous les éléments montrent qu'il n'a
pas été battu d'une manière régulière
est ce que vous sentez une véritable
scission dans la population américaine
aujourd'hui je pense que la population
américaine se divise en deux les du côté
des démocrates il ya des gens qui sont
gênés mais qui accepte devrait tout
puisque leurs candidats rentrent à la
maison blanche
mais du côté d'une bonne partie de la
population américaine
il ya des gens qui ont voté une
tradition très très cruel qui sont en
colère et qui sont dans le désarroi face
à ce qui se perd son temps à quoi cela
peut conduire je n'en ai aucune idée
maintenant il ya des gens qui parlent de
violence de guerre civile et ne pense
pas que ce sera le cas mais en tout cas
la situation est très malsaine
actuellement aux etats unis
et je pense qu'elle va le rester pendant
un certain temps parce que l'élection ne
s'est pas déroulé dans des conditions
normales
une élection ne donne pas de légitimité
joe biden est donc j'attends de voir ce
qui va se passer dans les mois à venir
même dans les semaines à venir mais je
pense que la situation est oui
très malsaine actuellement je le sens
quand je parle avec des voisins je le
sors pour ne pas lui des gens des think
tanks des siens trou de recherche pour
lesquelles je travaille j'ai publié
cette semaine un article très complet en
anglais sur le sujet qui est très dur
parce que je donne tout les détails de
toutes les péripéties très douteuse qui
se sont passées et je tiens à rajouter
quelque chose par rapport à ce qu'a dit
le secrétaire d'état de georgia donald
trump n'a pas voulu lui extorquer
quelques choses banales tram a énoncé
toutes les fraudes qui sont avérées les
plus violents que georgia et lui a dit
est ce que vous pouvez revenir sur votre
attitude parce que ce que vous faites
c'est très agréable et vous risquez
d'avoir des ennuis en justice et c'est
cela qui a été dit dans la conversation
entre la can ce burger et donald trump
ont hier et ça ce n'est pas dit dans le
washington post par exemple et ça n'est
pas dit dans les grands médias en
général et c'est cela qui s'est dit
effectivement et beaucoup de gens en
janvier sont persuadés qu'il y à eut
détruit ma cible et c'est ce qui crée
une incertitude pour l'élection de
demain parce que mon élection qui est
aujourd'hui de singles en france mais
pour nous cette enfant doué et donc
demain il ya des républicains qui
n'auront peut-être pas à voter parce que
ils se diront le système électoral mais
on ignore pas changer le système
quelques uns des fraudes étant toujours
là nous risquons d'avoir ne voient
confisquer à nouveau et je dirais que
c'est très très délicat comme situation
je dois dire qu'on ne sait pas ce que
sera le résultat de l'élection des deux
candidats au sénat demain et je dirais
que cette incertitude ne serait pas là
c'est en effet les manger bien indiqués
merci beaucoup de 10 milliards on va
suivre cela bien sûr sur rt france merci
en tout cas d'avoir réagi en direct de
las vegas ce matin dans la matinale
verte et france
[Musique]